obviously if you look in this country
just google
how many natural disasters occur in the
united states each year
and how many people are left homeless
because of these natural disasters
and then you will start understanding
why
disaster relief preparedness is
important
and so i've tried to do some of the
homework to keep you from spending 10
years that i've spent
trying to design this and i give all
credit to god i don't take any credit
for anything so you want to explain it
one more time and i'll just get on
camera
yeah today's lesson
is uh
is this kind of a applied research
on minimalist living
and what people would do confronted with
a disaster of large proportion
so that brings us to this which is
wickerjungle.com
no these domes are not made out of
wicker it just happens to be
on the website wickerjungle
so let me get to the point the
characteristics of this low-cost shelter
are this
if you'll look here this
right here is the top vent
and you can see it right here okay
so this is a close-up of this right here
so there's your top vent that you
prefabricate then
there's a ground hoop right here
that you prefabricate now we're looking
on a bird's eye view that means that
we're looking from the sky
down on top of this dome
the point is is that when you have a
shelter you want a shelter that is very
strong
why is this strong this is strong
because you can put bolts in all of
these intersections every one of these
you see so that when you finish this
thing is so strong
why is that of benefit in a disaster
well in a disaster
you know you could be flooded and you'd
want to be off the ground so you'd want
to be able to hang
hammocks you could get three hammocks
like here
here and here and it would hold it
you know with like a two 250 pound purse
and that kind of thing
all right so that would be an advantage
and a disaster
why also would it be an advantage
because
you could hang uh 50 pound bags of flour
for instance from the
the woven one-inch electrical pvc pipe
members
and uh and why is that a benefit well
again you're off the ground the only
thing that's prefabricated
on this entire dome is this star right
here
and this ground hoop once you have those
two
prefabricated everything else all these
other members
are 10 foot sections of electrical pvc
pipe is one inch in diameter so in other
words
all your labor is done once you make
this and that and this
so you could drop ship you know a
thousand of these
to some island that was you know flooded
or a hurricane disaster
they'd have a ship come in with the one
inch pvc pipe
and have a crew with nothing but bolts
and
and a drill and assemble these things in
no time
so that's why this uh this shelter
design is important
so the buzzword in
the disaster relief community is
um bang per buck in other words you want
a shelter that you have the most
bang per buck also one of the biggest
buzzwords
in disaster relief is a
mosquito lodge mosquito lodging because
typically when there's a flood or a
hurricane or something then the
mosquitoes become really bad
so you have thousands of people trapped
and everybody wants mosquito lodge well
proper shelter all revolves around
the ability to build the most shelters
with the least amount of money
so for four hundred dollars you have a
top vented
shelter all right why is top vented
important because you can put a stove
up out of the top if it's cold if it's
10 degrees below zero you would need a
way to vent
a stove you have a 193 square feet
so this is almost equivalent to a 14 by
14 bedroom
you won't find a tent anywhere like at
sam's wholesale or any of the uh
that that's gonna for the cost that's
going to give you
this many benefits so we're back to cost
benefit
analysis which is what all your buyers
do
in the disaster relief industry
so i challenge you to find
a better shelter system for the cost and
i'm not trying to oversell this i'm
really not i'm just trying to say that
that i think to be a responsible
consumer you need to always keep in mind
that
that there is a potential for
disasters all i can say is let's go
build some domes
let me play this song can i play this
song yeah go for it all right
this is called the dream song all right
this is
this is about that dream all right
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
way across the land
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
like a revolution
[Applause]
let's all make a plan
to live off the land
our earth is green
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
god
[Music]
a white house is a great house
[Music]
across the land
[Music]
they need to know just what you learned
follow me or i'll follow you
[Music]
if you want me to
[Applause]
let our people go
[Applause]
love will win again
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
and that's the dream song
you